believe it or not though there's even
more stupidity out there this time
coming from not the former people at fox
news like bill o'reilly but the current
people
on fox and friends on tuesday carly
shimkas decided to offer one of the most
idiotic takes
on why people should not
get the covid vaccine
she said this and this was actually they
were talking about the clip of trump and
o'reilly uh because apparently you know
slow dues week it's one of the biggest
things so she said this good for him
everybody should have the option to make
up their own mind about this about 74 75
percent of americans are at least
partially vaccinated that's a high
number
if you look at the reality of the
situation if somebody isn't vaccinated
right now and they look at their two
friends who between the three of them
had
six shots against covid and they still
got it because of omicron realistically
that person isn't going to get
vaccinated
so she's telling people
that because you can still get these
breakthrough infections which yes
they're becoming more common
that you just shouldn't get vaccinated
right
oh well they're vaccinated and they
still got it
so why would i bother getting vaccinated
well i don't know maybe because those
three people aren't dead
and here's the thing we're seeing more
breakthrough infections right now
because as i mentioned earlier in this
program the efficacy of the vaccines
does deteriorate over time and
unfortunately what we're seeing with
these covid19 vaccines the deterioration
is taking place over the course of about
six to nine months
you know relatively quickly i mean
that's about the half-life that we're
seeing off of these vaccines so
let me read i went through i compiled a
bunch of statistics here so let me read
this
just to counter her point
that you shouldn't get vaccinated if
you're going to get sick anyway
uh one large ongoing study of 780 000
veterans shows all three vaccines being
used in the u.s provide strong
protection against death from covid19
even as their efficacy against mild and
asymptomatic infection fell off
dramatically
researchers looking at men and women
getting treatment at veterans health
administration facilities found that
overall vaccine efficacy against all
types of infection fell from 87.9 in
february to 48 percent
in october they only counted fully
vaccinated veterans and these were done
via pcr tests
unvaccinated patients this is from
november
accounted for 91 percent of coven 19
deaths and nearly 94 percent of those
with a combined need for ventilators or
death
that's according to the journal of
american
of the american medical association
again from just last month so
does the vaccine prevent you from
getting sick
does it prevent you from having a
breakthrough infection
not necessarily you are still capable of
getting sick
even if you've been vaccinated and
boosted at this point
does it reduce your chances of getting
sick heck yeah
does it reduce your chances of dying
from covid19 or even being put on a
ventilator oh double heck yeah
that's what these numbers tell us 91 of
deaths
are unvaccinated
94 percent of deaths slash people on
ventilators unvaccinated
so if getting these shots knocks you
down
into a less than ten percent chance
of being one of the people who die from
this disease
would you not take that
would you not accept that risk when you
know what's waiting on the other side
and that is the part that people like
carly shemkus conveniently leave out of
their arguments
you know oh well people can still get
sick sure they can still get sick
you can still get the flu even if you've
had a flu shot
but you're less likely to get it as
severe
if you've had the vaccine and it's the
same thing with covid
what we're trying to do at the moment in
addition to slow the spread which let's
face it as a country we're really really
bad at that
we're trying to prevent more death
we're trying to prevent
long-term injury you know the
long-haulers they call them
i have some in my family
that had covered months ago
they still can't even climb a flight of
stairs without getting winded and having
to sit down
we don't know yet how severely
this virus is going to continue to
impact people year after year
and i'm not just talking about new waves
and new infections i'm talking about the
people who had the severe cases
and in the case of my family they didn't
end up on ventilators luckily they
didn't get that far
so this was just hospitalization from a
severe case that didn't quite get as
severe as some others
and this story is not unique uh new
orleans saints coach sean payton
it took him over two months
to get over his covet infection in the
early part of last year
and of course he recently was
re-diagnosed with covet again
but we're seeing these long haulers the
people with these long term issues
and and we don't even have enough time
yet under our belts
to fully understand
how bad it is going to affect these
people is it going to wear off in about
a year the effects of this they'll be
back to normal
or is this going to be a persistent
problem that opens them up to other
breathing complications in the future
other lung
ailments we don't know yet
so for all those people out there who
say oh we don't know what's in the
vaccines you don't know what's in
mountain dew either but you have no
problem guzzling that down
but more importantly
you don't know what the long-term
effects of covet are going to be on your
body
and i think it's a heck of a lot safer
to trust these vaccines
than to trust that this virus isn't
either going to kill you or permanently
damage your lungs
to where your life is forever altered
i think that's a pretty easy gamble
to take on the vaccines
i am farron cousins in for david pakman
you can find me on social media twitter
facebook instagram at fair and balanced
we'll be right back
the only streaming service that
specializes in documentaries is
curiosity stream and you can get
curiosity stream one of our sponsors for
just 15 bucks a year when you use my
link below this will give you access to
the world's best selection of
documentary films there's always
so many that you can't get on netflix
hulu or amazon
i just finished watching a tremendous
film the ceo of sinaloa sinaloa a region
of mexico it's about el chapo
fascinating fascinating curiosity stream
is a must-have
if you love documentaries they always
have the best and newest titles they're
always adding new things to the library
and you can watch on all of your devices
they've got documentaries on every topic
you can imagine curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off a subscription
making it just 15 bucks a month go to
curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below